hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Minecraft we're
still beating the crap out of grass and
by doing that we assert our dominance
over this land there's no reason to keep
you alive
there is only death I'm very slow oh
there sure are a lot of ma'am animals
around here and a lot of danimals around
here whoa how far down does that go do I
want to go down there there any reason
to go down there I should build some
ladders whoa look at the mountain anyway
I'm gonna kill these pigs can't really
run after him
well can I eat run flesh what does it do
for me it's something man
that probably wasn't a good idea what
did I get I don't know what that symbol
means
give me your wool give me your wool is
that a beehive I'm not gonna be able to
get bu you die I'm going to die I've
been poisoned by a bee oh okay
all right everyone calm or and finally
decided to calm down all right I got
bamboo I'm gonna take the bamboo back
because I'm gonna plant the bamboo
because for some reason I know I need
bamboo I don't remember exactly why I
need vampa but I know that bamboo is
required
why is bamboo required spam before you
will die pig
okay she's doing doing doing doing okay
maybe I should put the bamboo this one
no I don't have any dirt why don't I
have it a dirt you think that I would
have dirt delicious pork YUM okay so
what I need to do next is
[Music]
is build supplies so I can go on an
adventure yes that's it but an adventure
perfect
I'm gonna need food I'm gonna need
armoire I'm gonna need good tools and
I'm gonna need them now so I'm gonna do
that I need another iron pickaxe because
this one's about to Brooke I need to put
this away I need to put that away I need
to keep these and I need to make more
torches yes it's all coming together now
I made too many torches all right so
I've got my chops and I'm ready for a
venture Pig dad big yeah but probably
shouldn't laugh at that Karma's gonna
come get me I'm gonna go over to those
mountains because I'm pretty sure that a
mountain would be a better opportunity
for me than trying to dig in the ground
to try to get resources all I gotta do
is find the resources that are exposed
already above ground and then I you died
fast you - slow not nerman dead quick
[Applause]
yeah eventually I'll farm eventually you
know eggs prime just good nutritional
value but uh you'd be hard-pressed to
see me do that ooh that's a nice
mountain oh I need ladders
[Music]
all right hey I know I shouldn't be that
excited about iron but pretty excited
about iron hey and this adventure is
really paying off dividends oh hell yeah
hell yeah hell yeah hell yeah hell yeah
what do we got over here
hello whoo hey how you doing
No thank you no thank you no I don't
want any no can't see yet unbelievable
douche
is there someone about to stab me there
better not be something about to stab me
I swear if there's someone that step
yeah yeah yeah there's no one I really
need coal but I kind of want cool kiz'
kind of nice
hey no no no I know I'm out and Brawl
gonna be out at night but I'm prepared
for it I think Oh am I supposed to wait
until my charge kind of like builds up
so spamming is not the right way
interesting I'm learning more every day
I'm learning I am so smart
what are those berry bushes yum yum yum
please yes thank you
oh ouch all right so what's up in the
mountain what kind of what kind of
what-have-you is in the mountain oh
that's pretty
oh that's pretty oh that's so pretty
oh my god it's pretty where's this ax
pretty all eclipse Oh trust that all
that done seemed good that don't seem
good none at all it's gonna be like
exposed or somewhere ow
what do we got here hope Wow hello hello
hello nothing there's nothing over here
it's just a bunch of dirt I mean what
honestly could be exposed up I guess I
guess that is the question
what do i what am I expecting to find
I'm just kind of wanting to go on an
adventure I don't really have any plans
oh oh it's supremely more effective to
wait I'm just an idiot I've been doing
it so wrong this whole time
why have you guys allowed me to do it so
it's not above-ground lava hell yeah no
no no archers please thank you know our
church no no no no sweet berries I might
kill these cows I might need their
leather they give leather right thanks
for the beef womp-womp-womp boom out
Wham
oh it's waiting is the best I am so
stupid you really want them but he
really want me oh wow whoa honey
whoa hell oh stop it
oh you tiny bastard oh no no no no not
like this not like this fall into chasm
fall into chasm and die little kill me I
need to eat some berries excuse me oh
gosh shove him in my gob Oh
shove them in my gob I didn't mean to
plan the Oh
the tiny one you a-hole no stop please
no not like this I don't want it please
no why is this burning over here oh oh
[Music]
[Applause]
fine ride ride me so stupid stupid I'm
dominum stupid stupidness what's with
the tiny zombies horrible the little
bastards alright I need to take a
logical approach to this it's my own
hubris that is causing my own demise I'm
going out with the complete expectation
that I am immune and incapable of
encountering any danger even though I
don't even have any armor my own hubris
is the end of me I need to think about
it logically and I need to approach the
situations reasonably and I need to come
at them without need to come out then
with a level head so that when I get in
danger it won't actually be bad and I'm
gonna bother I'm hurrying back to my
body so that I can get the materials
that I have lost and I will definitely
get there in time I will not have to
worry ended the landmark is easy because
it's by the lava perfect easy done
victory is mine that's what a level that
will get you a jump I see it I see my
experience on the ground as well this is
perfect this will end well for me yes
actually
holy crap it's all here it kind of
drifted in in the current a bit but it's
all here technically speaking not always
lost not all that wander is lost no yes
yes yes please thank you this is great
this is fantastic this is amazing do I
have everything
no there's something that drifted down
here okay this is good this may not seem
good but it's good this was a life
lesson I lost a lot of experience but
hey I gained a lot of hutzpah and that's
what really matters in the end
Wow please I'm out of let's find Intuit
blue let me know oh god there's so many
arts there's so many archers there's so
many archers why are there so many
archers oh my god I didn't get my sward
on me or okay get it on the bar quickly
ah Go Go that's a flower how did I get a
flower on my bar okay
level head even keel I'm out of the
woods basically the sun's gonna come up
and it's gonna burn away all the evil
there it is beautiful that is pretty I
gotta admit that that's real pretty
right there crisis averted
okay I'm gonna get back to base now
thank you very much thank you thank you
all so much this is too perfect
what what what didn't the fresh hell was
that nothing apparently a whole lot of
nothing oh my mistake
I assumed the horrible noise of death
was something but it turns out actually
nothing turns out just nothing you know
my egg on my face
I'm just gonna ignore that do I just boy
sit pretend like I didn't hear that
do I just pretend like that never
happened did we just pretend we all
right we just pretend everybody
collectively you've forgotten now that
whatever the hell that was happened you
know I'm just gonna I'm just gonna I'm
just gonna go I'm just gonna go okay all
right I'm back in my base and to build
my farm sounds like the most ideal farm
layout ever in the history of any thing
but at worst I've got a bunch of iron to
melt I have eggs that I could cook I
need to make some more for nooses yes
please thank you and then plop that bad
boy there BAM
got it Robbie's
I don't know what this amazing table is
for must be something about maybe like
upgrading things but I don't know how to
upgrade things yet so that's really
entirely useless to me much like most
things in this world are just completely
useless to me
oh I'm gonna have to lug all this water
over bah all right fine okay steal from
I can yes yes unlimited water that it
makes no sense but I love it I love just
minecraft logic yeah all right now these
bad boys will stay tilled alright
properly irrigated I can properly plant
lob I do label it deal add a douche
perfect I don't have nearly enough for
any of that and the sun's going this day
the day doesn't if they they don't last
too long they they don't last is the
thing they really don't last alright do
I at least have iron do I leave that
beef can I do I have a beef can I get
beef can beef please beef me I can make
leather pants yes that was probably the
least efficient thing that I could have
made no I feel like early wasted that
yeah I could have made the tunic oh that
would have been but I can make even
better I can make iron I can make iron
chestplate oh that's even better
oh these bastards oh these bastards they
thought they could get me no no no no no
I have brown bats no little notice when
I shook them out of there okay so this
is actually turning out quite well for
me I'm very proud of myself because I am
amazing
I can also plant my sugar cane I don't
think there's anything special that you
need for sugar cane I think it just
grows no it don't doesn't need like
onion tilled oh yeah untilled that's
right that's right that's right that's
really okay perfect perfect
what the hell do you think you are what
the hell do you think you are I'll have
you know I graduated top of my class
god I need like a fence above here
people are just gonna be dropping in out
of nowhere I did not think through
having my base in the pit in the hole in
the ground of course me markiplier saw a
hole in the ground was like yeah perfect
it's ultimate defense no one will be
able to come find me oh crap
they found me no no yeah yeah that's
what I thought they didn't make him
tougher they just made me dumber alright
No thank you for dying
alright perfect I'll build a fence later
god I could have made it like on a
mountaintop you know anything better
than a hole in the ground but no I mean
markiplier decided that I must make my
face a hole in the ground
oh god I'm tremendously stupid also I
think is there like a monster in here
[Applause]
what's going on hello I've actually got
armor this time so I think I'm actually
gonna oh crap alright you know what I
don't even know why I shouldn't be
concerned with the mumbling my is that
mature yes he was I don't know if it was
completely mature dammit I wasn't ready
it was one week please they call me one
wheat mark oh hello how are you mind if
I murder you I'm going to murder you
okay no you cannot you cannot you cannot
last
oh are you scary oh you
[Music]
where did you go yeah it's fine
yeah that's but that's totally fine sure
sure yeah yeah yeah you know what whoa I
see you I see you you think you can mess
with the likes of me you dead you dead
I've got your pearl you got your pearl
you bastard god I forgot this game was a
horror game it's not a nice Pleasant
game of exploration and riches nuts it's
just straight horror the whole time I'm
gonna make some iron pants because I got
a funny feeling I'm gonna need an
upgrade here yeesh
forget this leather out of here put that
away all right I got my battle pants on
I got my beef in my hand I'm ready now
this time I'm gonna go out on an
adventure and I'm gonna kick some
serious butt tuchus and this time I'm
gonna go this way I'm gonna go to
escalator land all right I'll be back
once I make some headway and I'm gonna
I'm gonna go on a venture maybe I'll
find a town or something maybe I'll find
something nice what what what oh is this
an arrow is this an arrow pointing down
wait is this like a treasure why else
would there be a giant floating block in
the sky dirt what maybe I shouldn't
drink straight down the farther down I
get the more I realize I might be an
idiot
I think I'm an idiot I think it's really
dumb to think that a floating thing in
the sky was an arrow and not just like
some generated bug like an artifact it
wasn't really a thing it was a bug I'm
beginning to realize I'm an idiot a hey
redstone
that's cool hey my first redstone that's
great
it was a treasure map after all how do I
make a ladder ah hell yeah get me out of
here
oh I'm freakin genius
god I'm smart get me out of here I hope
this is enough to get out here cuz I'm
so smart god I'm a genius of epic
proportions except I might run out of
might be a little short on the genja
shovels no I'm good now this is enough
it's gonna make it night I'll make it
it'll make it it'll make it I got just
enough just enough yeah I got plenty
plenty just enough God come on kids find
the gold it's totally worth the bay
because watch this John use time alright
never mind
god dammit John you stuck all right John
you escape route activate super smart
damn it oh crap I didn't just come to
get the genius table like at the bottom
here's Dorcas door oh ok spray it's
bright so bright
Junius time incoming Johnny's back at
the judge's table building another
journeys pickaxe Jenny's incoming
youngest I'm so humble and humble mmm
humble - did you know I should shut up
Lexie and just any time I do something
like that just cut me off and replayed
replace me with text-to-speech to say
how humble I am please woo no I didn't
kill your brother cuz you're all one
interconnected being oh god it's night
and raining alright it was a very dumb
idea I get it I get that now I'm gonna
get back home okay I get it I get it I'm
an idiot
well why why why why does it do that why
does it do that why does it think that's
okay to do that's not okay to do an or
games it's not okay to do it in
Minecraft which is a game meant for
babies which I am NOT one I'm a man I'm
a man I'm a man okay I'm back home
thank God it's so bright and vivid with
all of these porches also I collected
some extra wood on the way back because
because because I'm about to show you
just how smart I am I'm about to show
you the absolute pinnacle of genius
because because because in let me let me
let me talk to you about this because
because because because because my goal
very important because hold on all right
I'm about to show you just how smart I
is all right now you may look at me and
you may see a man who is both handsome
and awesome in every way however what
you are also going to see is a man who
pushes the limits of human capacity some
may say it's a bad idea to dig straight
down but what if and I tell you this
what if what if when you dig straight
down God take this stuff down take these
what if what if cuz I know I know the
threat of digging straight down is what
if you hit lava but if you don't have
anything on you worth keeping and you
dig straight down what do you have to
lose all you have to do is gain all you
get is gained
you just get gains there is no loss all
right hello
Oh over louvered over see are you seeing
my genius my genius knows no limits oh
my god
I'm so smart oh it's cute whoa whoa oh
yeah you know I'm not gonna dig anything
just yet just in case I fall in I oh no
no I don't have anything to fight you
you're fine just don't fight me you
wouldn't want to anyway who this oh oh
oh this is what I was talking about oh
this is in fact what I was talking about
oh yeah why oh god geez I don't have on
my armor ah that got really close you
know if I didn't know any better I
thought that was kind of trying to hit
me oh I'm being flown into the lava why
don't you just go jump in a lava pit
douche yeah that's right loser see I'm a
genius so you guys thought that you were
messing with the average intelligence
person turns out there's out far beyond
far far beyond okay so now what's gonna
happen is you guys are about to see me
get my first diamond that's what's about
to happen just so you know I'm not gonna
what is andesite andesite I have no idea
what Anderson is redstone baby good exp
anything god damn it is nothing there's
no point
god damn it all right this may have been
bupkis but hey you know it's it's pretty
cool down here though right oh my
goodness
oh you're still here oh god no no not
like this oh please no not like this I
don't actually have any food on me oh
please no not like this do not not one
more not one more hit oh that was too
close
okay alright you know I learned my
lesson I don't want to be here are you
okay we're fine okay where did I fall
down where's my hole
whereas the hole that was meant for me
how far did I explore a near where did I
go oh I know where I went okay good all
right I'm gonna keep going don't
continue the genius hole did I bring I
did not bring the ladders with I didn't
bring them I didn't bring the ladders
with
I didn't bring the ladders with me I
gotta fill this bad boy up oh well now I
know now I know that holes safe to dig
straight down in now I know see that's
what I really wanted to discover is to
know if it was safe and now I know I
feel so stupid huh so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to check out the new cloak
minecraft collection it's available at
cloak brand calm link is in the
description cloak brand calm sea loa
KBRA and e.com go check it out there's
an amazing new set of items just there
for you for the release of minecraft
dungeon which I will be playing
eventually thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]